den namen des französischen volkes das
erste permanente kriegsgericht
militärregierung von paris hat in seiner
sitzung vom 22
dezember 1894 einstimmig den wie folgt
genannten angeklagten dreyfus alfred
kapitän des 14
regiments anwärter für den generalstab
der armee des hochverrats für schuldig
befunden man kann über den film intrige
nicht reden ohne gleichzeitig auch über
seinen regisseur zu sprechen über roman
polanski der nun schon seit mehr als 40
jahren der vergewaltigung in amerika
angeklagt ist und deswegen in paris lebt
auch deswegen weil ein
auslieferungsersuchen gegen ihn vorliegt
und der um das mindeste zu sagen eine
umstrittene persönlichkeit ist
dennoch muss ich jetzt über diesen film
reden so als hätte ihnen jemand anders
gerät oder besser gesagt als hätte ihn
nicht der im ständigen rampenlicht wegen
seiner verfehlungen oder einer
unterstellten verfehlungen stehende
polanski gedreht einzige ausnahme ist
ständig mannschaft hat
kannst du es auch beweisen ich möchte
keinen skandal es ist bereits ein
skandal
solltest paris wenige zeit als du
ich habe die ehre ihnen müsse im mehl
solar vorzustellen jemand muss die ganze
geschichte auf den linken als offizier
dass ich darüber nicht schreibt sehen
nicht aber ich schon wenn man es so
sieht dann ist intrige ein sehr
gelungener sehr klassischer sehr
konservativer sehr standardmäßiger film
über eine intrige die frankreich in den
1990 er jahren bis in die grundfesten
erschüttert hat die dreyfus affäre
wenn wir herausfinden dass dreyfus nicht
der fall ist sollten wir im interesse
der ami rasch handeln
außer kolonne wir werden ihre befehle
befolgt
ich will auf keinen fall eine weitere
dreyfus affäre das ist keine weitere
dreyfus affäre
es ist dieselbe die dreyfus affäre dreht
sich im kern um eine anklage wegen
spionage gegen einen jüdisch ständigen
französischen hauptmann der verurteilt
wurde weil er angeblich unterlagen an
den dort an die deutschen an das
deutsche reich verraten hat der
militärische unterlagen und an dessen
fall sich der ganze zwiespalt der
französischen öffentlichkeit zwischen
einerseits antisemitismus bornierten
patriotismus andererseits liberaler
freiheitlicher nach gerechtigkeit
streben intellektuelle öffentlichkeit
manifestiert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
diesen skandal diese affäre hat polanski
um den abend doch wieder zu nennen
einfach eine absolut vorbildlicher weise
ins bild gesetzt
es gibt sequenzen die kann man sich
sozusagen bild für bild noch mal
anschauen auf der zunge zergehen lassen
so wunderbar reibungslos sind sie
aufgenommen und geschnitten zu klassisch
im hitchcock shen sinne die straße
liefen kreieren nein noch besser ein
felsen auf dem er ganz allein ist die
teufelsinsel
[Musik]
er hat die crème der französischen
schauspieler vorher seiner kamera gehabt
jean buscher da in der hauptrolle nicht
des majors dreyfus sondern des colonels
picard der den fall ein zweites mal
untersucht und letztlich entscheidend
zur rehabilitierung von alfred dreyfus
beiträgt in weiteren rollen als dreyfus
louis garrel als schrift
sachverständiger mathieu amalric als
anwalt melville popo es sind lauter
große schauspieler die da vor der kamera
stehen und entsprechend großartig ist
der ganze film gespielt aber auch viele
unterschiede dass das doppel erst das
sagen sie selbst ja aber das ist absicht
das ist die fälschung seiner eigenen
handschrift überhaupt wenn sie zu wollen
und vergessen sie auch nicht dass das
begleitschreiben auf einem extrem dünnen
papier geschrieben wurde
wie dieses hier normalerweise benutzt
niemand sowas als briefpapier
dadurch ist es möglich war doch die
kritiken sie eine perfekte transparenz
zu haben und dann darunter ein muster zu
benutzen eine vorlage die eine flüssige
handschrift was man aber auch sagen muss
mehr als diese affäre mehr als dieser
historische fall ist eben auch nicht zu
sehen
das heißt es handelt sich hier letztlich
um ein fiktives oder halb fiktives
dokumentarisches spiel mit realen
schauplätzen mit realen vorbildern mit
realen geschehnissen was in zwei stunden
sehr sehr ordentlich über die leinwand
läuft aber wieder tief berührt noch
besonderen glanz verströmt ist ein film
den wenn ein anderer regisseur gedreht
hätte wir vielleicht nicht mit einem so
aufmerksamen so aufgeregt und blick
betrachten würden ein film allerdings
über antisemitismus die uns auch heute
noch angeht der heute noch aktuell ist
ein fall der uns weiterhin beschäftigen
sollte